?
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO PRETEND
THAT WE ARE RIGHT WHEN WE COME
TO SITUATIONS.
WE ARE THE MEDIA.
WE ARE TERRIBLE AND RUSHING TO
JUDGMENT.
WE PUSH OUT A LOT OF INACCURATE
MATERIAL.
A LOT OF THE FACTS THAT HAVE
COME OUT IN THIS STORY HAVE
TURNED OUT NOT TO BE TRUE.
SO WE ARE GETTING ANOTHER BITE
IN THE APPLE OF THE STORY AND I
JUST WOULD RATHER JUST PULL BACK
INSTEAD OF STARTING TO CONDEMN
PEOPLE.
WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE AND
WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE NOT DONE
BECAUSE THE FACTS ALWAYS END UP
CHANGING.
IT ALWAYS DOES.
SO I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
BENEFIT TO PUSHING OUT
INFORMATION, WHETHER IT'S
INACCURATE OR NOT BECAUSE
FRANKLY, WHAT THE HELL DO WE
KNOW?
REALLY.
WHAT THE HELL DO WE KNOW?
>> Judge Jeanine: WE DON'T
KNOW.
WE WEREN'T THERE.
KATIE, PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THE
OTHER DAY WITH HIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER HE WAS GOING TO LIMIT THE
TRANSFER OF MILITARY HARDWARE TO
POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
HAVE THESE POLICE OFFICERS HAVE
BALLISTIC SHIELDS, DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGY, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL IT, THEY COULD HAVE GONE
AND WITHOUT WAITING AN HOUR.
THEY COULD HAVE CONFRONTED HIM.
>> Katie: I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU
BROUGHT THAT UP BECAUSE I WAS
GOING TO BRING IT UP.
DHS HAS BEEN CAPABLE OF
TRANSFERRING MILITARY TYPE
EQUIPMENT TO LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS LIKE A VOLTE TEXAS,
VERY SMALL TOWN THAT DOESN'T
HAVE ENORMOUS RESOURCES, THEY
DON'T HAVE A BIG TAX BASE SO
THEY NEED FUNDING OR EQUIPMENT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
BE ON THE SAME LEVEL IN TERMS OF
THEIR TRAINING SHOULD SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPEN IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
IT'S DIFFICULT.
IT'S EXPENSIVE.
THE TRAINING TAKES A LOT OF
TIME.
THAT'S ONE ASPECT OF THIS.
THE OTHER IS AS WE NOW SEE IN
THE REPORTING OF THE PRESS
CONFERENCE TODAY, THERE WAS NOT
AN ARMED OFFICER ON THE SCENE.
THE DOOR WAS UNLOCKED FOR THE
GUY TO WALK RIGHT INTO THE
SCHOOL.
THERE WAS NO SECURITY AT ALL.
NONE, THERE WAS NOTHING TO STOP
THIS PERSON.
THERE WAS NOTHING TO SLOW HIM
DOWN.
NO DETERRENT.
IT WAS TOO LATE.
THE OLD SAYING IS WHEN SECONDS
COUNT, THE POLICE ARE MINUTES
BEHIND AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
IT'S INTERESTING TO LOOK AT THE
TIME LINE WITH BORDER PATROL
SHOWING UP.
UVALDE IS ABOUT 50 MILES FROM
THE BORDER.
I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW THE EVENTS
THERE AND WHY A S.W.A.T. TEAM
COULDN'T GET THERE MORE QUICKLY.
THE VIDEO OF THE POLICE STANDING
OUTSIDE WITH LONG GUNS, WHAT
KIND OF FIREARM DID THE INITIAL
POLICE OFFICERS GO INTO THE
SCHOOL WITH?
DO THEY JUST GO IN WITH HAND
GUNS OR RIFLES?
LOTS OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THEY
HANDLE THAT BUT THE IDEA THAT
THERE WAS NO SINGLE THING TO
STOP THIS PERSON CHANGES
EVERYTHING.
IMAGINE IF THE DOOR WAS LOCKED.
WE LEARNED FROM PARKLAND THAT
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THE DOORS
CLOSE.
>> Judge Jeanine: IN THE
NIKOLAS CRUZ CASE.
AND NOW WE FIND OUT THAT THE
DOOR WAS NOW CLOSE.
ALSO THAT THE DISTRICT EMPLOYEES
FOUR SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS,
THE UVALDE SCHOOL DISTRICT.